jenna is with us in Kansas hi Jenna
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thank you so much for taking the time to
talk to me certainly welcome at all yeah
so my husband and I are married for five
years and we are at a point when we're
disgusted and tired and we're ready to
finally get out of debt we mapped out
our budget and our plan and we feel like
we can have our ninety seven thousand
dollars in consumer debt paid off in
about two to three years at maximum
great and and my question is though we
know how much we can throw at our debt
monthly but we bought a home three years
ago and we have a relatively low
mortgage so we know it's a good place to
stay and allow us to pay off even more
but the house is falling apart in some
regards and it's 75 years old and it
needs some serious repair that I just
don't know how to budget for those
repairs that are necessary that we can't
wait until the years goes by to fix them
well you slow down you're getting out of
debt and you pay cash for the repairs or
you don't do them okay so we just
prioritize them and go from there what
about just selling the money pit and
moving we don't have very much equity in
the house so we so I guess I just don't
know really what that looks like let me
tell you if you sold it and you'd broke
even and you went and rented something
you're not having to write checks for
repairs every month while you're trying
to get out of debt and you just increase
the quality of your life because you're
living in a dump yeah absolutely that is
an option yeah I'll just get rid of it
cuz here's what happens with most people
when they buy a house to do a renovation
while they're living in it it sucks the
marrow out of your bones yeah that's
where the money you ever say that pit
that old movie that was cheesy as crud
called the money pit yeah yeah it was an
over drought dramatization of how most
people feel when they do a renter
while they're living in the house it's a
very difficult thing to do emotionally
to renovate a house over a four or five
year period of time
while you're living in it it drains you
it's strange your relationship it drains
your money it may you know you're just
getting tired of dealing with the crap
am I wrong am I wrong no okay that's
that's where most people when you go
into it you go hey we got a deal and I'm
kind of handy and I can do this stuff
and we'll do it and unless you push on
through that in about six months it gets
really really old and you're way past
the really old part I'd get out of there
if I were you and just get you another
get you another place after you get out
of debt and you can decide whether you
want to do a renovation again this time
or not I don't mind doing renovations
I've bought a lot of properties that
we've rehabbed but not while people
lived in them and a couple of times
we've done some pretty massive
redecorating
Sharon decides we have to do that ever
so often just shoot me but it's
something she understands and I don't so
we're doing it but even that level of
just stuff being torn up for four or
five weeks while they're running paint
and putting up new little crap on the
wall or whatever it is they're gonna do
that drives me bananas just just over a
period of weeks but to do it for months
or years it's just too harsh I wouldn't
do it you do what you want to do but I
don't see many people do that
successfully